questo essere insieme reder questo gioco
bello preferiresti ragazzi avere il 50
per cento di possibile che cazzo dico
anno questa le risposte sono scemo
questo viaggio mia mi ha fatto male rega
preferiresti avere la possibilità di
teletrasportarsi o essere in grado di
viaggiare nel tempo oddio mica
bruttissimo nate trasportarmi a perché
ho già scelto da entrava il bene
preferisce gli per me preferiresti avere
il mal di pancia o mal di testa mal di
pancia perché mal di testa mi dà
fastidio
già non un cervello seppure mal di testa
non so che caso farmene da questa parte
in su del corpo preferisce ma perché mi
mette già le scelte non lo fate
preferiresti forzate a guardare my
little pony per 24 ore
oppure avere la canzone di ma l'iter
pony in testa per il resto la tua vita
che come fa la canzone di maritele pony
fuori specie ma credo che dante quando
ha disegnato la sua mappa dell'inferno
si sia dimenticato un girone che quello
che gli stronzi o degli hate forziamo
gli haters ad ascoltare questa merda per
il resto della loro vita se dovessi fare
un qualcosa tutte le mattine
preferiresti munger ti oppure fare le
uova io comunque tutte le mattine cago
le uova tanto cagni è uguale preferire
stiviere per sempre o fino alla fine
dell'universo oppure morire adesso senza
nessuno che cazzo di domanda è lo va a
fan culo da chi ha messo la base decenni
ma siete tutti scemi perché avrei dove
sceglie di morire le ferie sti essere
allergico ai bambini o allergico alle
persone vecchie ma basta che eviti
cantieri c'è non ha senso
vabbè i pedofili qua frias essere
allergico la tua ragazza preferita sì
che la tua ragazza fosse incinta
nei prossimi dieci secondi oppure sapere
che non potrebbe mai più fare figli
però io non ho una ragazza 69 bravi
ragazzi preferiresti pagare per vedere
un una comica a donna oppure pagare la
stessa cifra per essere schiaffeggiato
dieci volte in faccia ma io non avevo
neanche bisogno di pagare per vedere una
comica donna ogni volta che mi diceva ti
amo mi metto a ridere
quindi questo no ha sbagliato era
l'altro preferiti avere un appuntamento
alla cieca con un senzatetto si vabbè ma
un senzatetto donna spero quindi un
senzatetto per avere un appuntamento a
ceca con una senza una tetta che va
benissimo preferiresti essere
telecinetico e telepatico mica
bellissimo telecinetico preferiresti
essere bloccato sulla luna o bloccato
sul fondo dell'oceano [ __ ] ma
[ __ ] guarda preferiresti
abbracciare un panda o un orso polare
panda quando tutta la vita sono troppo
teneri con preferirsi essere ricercato
per omicidio ed essere sempre in fuga
oppure essere un senzatetto aridaje così
senza tetto che ha soltanto i boxer
[Musica]
perché ha soltanto i boxer omicidio
mezzo di domande preferiresti essere
famoso in questa vita o andare nei libri
di storia non lo so preferisco essere
socrate che miley cyrus con una casa
scritto ciao nei libri di storia dai per
ferie dover dormire tre ore tutti i
giorni o dormire 15 ore tutti i giorni
di questa forse lo avevo anche già fatta
se dormo tre ore tutti i giorni non vivo
sono morto quindi però anche quindi ci
sono troppe porca eva tre ore tutti i
giorni il problema è che non non sarebbe
sarei uno zombie nello studio
preferiresti mangiare essere umani per
il resto della tua vita oppure morire di
fame state pensando ciò che sto pensando
io ragazzi nel dubbio vi metto la sila
[Musica]
occhio gul per l'amor di dio e freschi
vivere da solo su un'isola tropicale o
vivere con altre persone in antartide da
solo ma tutta la vita brucia [ __ ] ma
che in antartica mica fa un freddo cane
preferiresti non poter mai lasciare il
tuo paese o non essere mai in grado di
guidare io guarda ciò viaggio sempre
quindi la prima impossibile inoltre non
ho la patente quindi a posto feste avere
una pepsi ha una coca cola a me giuro su
dio mi piace di più la pepsi non so
perché non ho idea preferissi bruciare
fino alla morte oppure annegare annegare
credo sia meno doloroso sempre 69 grazie
preferiresti lanciarti su della lava ma
adesso tutto è così brutto adesso
lanciati su della lava oppure lanciarti
in uno tsunami bank però credo che
lanciarsi sul nostro ma mi sia più figo
ceco si sa più di noi quando morì il
cassano morto in uno tsunami perché ho
avuto le palle d'acciaio mi sono buttata
in proprio da quaterback la gente
preferisce buttarsi nella la pensate
preferiresti parlare davanti alla
nazione intera oppure dormire con delle
tarantole nel tuo letto
preferireste essere nell'universo di
fallout nell'universo di skyrim fallout
mag ma guarda aspettiamo con altri 2 3
anni con donald trump
lo scopriamo subito quindi facciamo
skyrim preferireste essere un buffo devo
dire gufo notebook cazzo è un hoc
nacqui da out falcon falco un falco uno
squalo falco falco ep figo perché caghi
in testa la gente pezzi di merda così va
dai ragazzi facciamo le ultime tre
giusto per sicurezza voglio vedere che
cazzo esce fuori a caso preferirsi
essere forzato a guardare il film che ho
di più e più volte per una settimana o
ascoltare la canzone che ho di più e più
volte per una settimana
forse
vabbè posso andare almeno a cagare si
spera non lo so forse il film no il film
la canzone dai mica il film veramente
brutto per finire si giocare a come un
quarterback come un linebacker che non
so che cosa sia perché non mi intendo di
rugby e se io dovessi mai giocare a
rugby e mi facessero mai un placcaggio
mi trovano in cui bechis ton quaterback
almeno coro preferiresti questo non mi
piace questo non mi piace questa vi
piace perfetti essere una uno shot gun
un'arma crossa un'arma grossa oppure
un'arma ad una mano sola
io credo che lo shot gun si è molto più
filo molto più figo da ancora una volta
mi sento carico preferiresti parlare
come yoda o respirare come darth vader
romica rimorchiare con la voce idiota e
dura ai ragazzi respira come darth vader
buona fortuna ragazzi ma avere amici
belli io direi che fossero chiudere qui
questo video è sempre più in senso sto
gioco però però vabbè tanto siamo
abituati al suo gioco quindi non è un
problema però è questo video vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa se sì vi è
piaciuto il momento è un mi piace anche
vari social che come hai visto
descrizione la testa insieme ci vediamo
il prossimo video si trovasse il
telecomando
sarebbe molto figo però non c'è quindi
so se questi ti scateni ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi